So to close out this course, let's talk a little bit about lighting in Unreal Engine.
So we have some lighting definitions and types.
We talk a little bit about static versus dynamic and then also the different lighting types
that you can see inside of Unreal.
So the lighting definitions might be useful to start off with here.
So direct lighting is light that falls onto a surface without any interference.
Light travels directly to the surface and the surface receives a full color spectrum
of light.
So that's direct lighting in Unreal Engine.
Indirect or balanced lighting is lighting that has been then reflected by the surfaces
nearby.
So you can see in the bottom right hand corner here, we've got some indirect lighting that
is almost lifting that backside of the sphere to give it a bit of balanced light off the
floor onto the sphere to give you a nicer more realistic effect.
So as light bounces off these surfaces, light waves are absorbed or reflected based on
the surface properties and passed to the surface you're looking at.
So again, when we're talking about PBR and we're talking about surface properties, this
all plays a part in getting your realistic lighting and how much metallic and roughness
and the bounce lighting that you have going on.
All these properties work together to get your desired lighting result.
So indirect lighting contributes to the mood and overall light intensity.
When we talk about shadows, shadows happen when Unreal Engine takes a snapshot of a mesh
from a light's point of view and projects that information onto another mesh actor on
the opposite side.
So you can toggle lights between static and dynamic lighting.
Bait lighting is pre-computed rendered lighting.
Bait lighting is created using Unreal Lightmass, a radiosity baker.
And similar to rendering lighting in V-Ray or Corona or any of the other lighting tools
that you might be used to, it's used to create high quality indirect lighting using light
and shadow maps and it's baked lighting cannot be altered at runtime.
Because it's been pre-computed, you can edit that at runtime because all the light maps
and shadow maps have been baked in pre-rendered.
It has little impact on real-time performance with that.
So if you're worried about performance and you want all the lighting controlled and baked,
that's the route to take.
Your real-time, in quotations, dynamic lighting is a type of lighting that is updated with
each frame.
It's fully dynamic and can be moved around and modified at runtime.
Historically it has no global illumination component, only a direct light.
It can also be really expensive.
You want to make sure there's not too many overlapping real-time dynamic lights.
Unreal Engine can use both static and dynamic lighting in comparison.
You don't have to pre-select whether you want all static or all dynamic.
You can have, say, 85% you've seen static with 15% dynamic lighting where you might
need it.
So for archviz projects, typically stationary, which is kind of an intermediary between static
and dynamic.
So stationary lighting inside of Unreal Engine is baked lighting that can accommodate dynamic
actors.
Ray tracing is a type of real-time lighting.
Its global illumination is updated with all lights set to movable.
If they are animated, the global illumination updates on the fly.
But ray tracing is worth noting, requires advanced GPU hardware.
So when we have our different light types that we're talking about, this place actors
tab in our editor, as we saw when we were looking at the geometry tab before, you have
a light tab and you can see all the different lights that you can select from.
So when we're talking about directional light, which is essentially a sunlight or a moonlight
source, you can drag and drop directional lights into your map.
You've got point lights, which are omni lights, spotlights, rectangle lights, skylights.
Laser can catch in the environment, HDR image based ambient light.
HDR backdrops, which is a blueprint that helps you set up the light in your scene based on
a HDR image.
And the sun sky, which is a new feature in Unreal Engine, is a blueprint that automates
the sun position in the sky based on geographical location.
So if you want realistic time of day, that sun sky tool will really help you out very
quickly.
So the data and components, all the things that we require in the scene, we have a light
source for the sun, generally a directional light, atmosphere, preferably linked to the
sun to adapt its position.
And then we also have a post-process volume, which is around the scene that can adjust
the lighting solution, another end in aspects.
So the post-process volume, again, we have courses on this in more detail, but essentially
a post-process volume can be placed around a scene if you want it just within this specific
place to affect the rendering aspects.
You can actually, on the post-process volume, if you have one in your scene and you type
unbound, you can actually say this post-process should impact the entire world if you wanted
to.
So have a play around with post-processing.
There's a lot of powerful functionality there.
And then optional things are skylights to contribute to global illumination, a sky dome
for a backdrop visual.
You can have volumetric clouds.
And if you want to use a light mass importance volume, you can.
It's only needed for baked lighting and not needed when using lumens.
So if you want to control your scene with static lighting, light mass importance volume
will really help those bake times and give you the best quality static lighting.
But essentially you can see all the different components in this diagram to help you set
up the scenes in the way that you would like.